Sure,
I'm not far from [inaudible],
which I mentioned is a ps 28,
which is bed Stuy,
the other side of Atlantic Avenue.
Uh,
this is a school where over 40 percent
of the kids are homeless.
Uh,
and uh,
the,
the principal there is 30 for a highly.
It's a highly,
highly effective school,
high performing school.
Um,
the principal there,
she,
when I,
when I took a tour there last year,
she introduced me to his secretary.
She said,
I've trained my secretary to do most of
my administrative jobs.
I said,
well,
what do you do?
She says,
I am the lead teacher at the school.
I'm in classrooms all day.
I work with teachers and I teach the
kids.
The teachers don't know how to teach
because I want to make it clear to my
teachers that I didn't become a
principal to escape the classroom.
I became a principal to be the leader of
the classrooms.
And I watched her as she interacted
with,
with teachers and it was very clear that
she saw them as colleagues,
as part of a team that even though she
was clearly the leader,
she was also there to support them.
Uh,
and uh,
at one point I said,
well,
how do you get along with your union?
She said,
let me introduce you to my union Rep.
and it was very clear that they were
partners in this effort and working well
together.
So,
you know,
what she has is something that is very
difficult to teach a is,
which is a high degree of social
intelligence.
She knows how to work with people.
She knows how to bring the best out of
people.
She knows how to read people and
understand their strengths.
Uh,
at one point when I was listening at
school,
um,
she said she took me to a,
a small office where there was an older
man counseling a little boy.
And I said,
uh,
she said,
you see that man there?
I said,
yeah.
And she says,
uh,
I got him from the rubber room.
Now a,
those people who don't know New York or
the rubber room is a place where they
put a teachers and school staff that
nobody wants and they stay there
indefinitely and get paid and it's a,
it's a really horrendous situation.
So I said to her,
I said,
how did you know to get them out of the
rubber room?
She said,
well,
I don't know why he was there,
but he had been my counselor when I was
a kid in school.
So when I heard he was in the rubber
room,
I asked for him and I bought into my
school.
So I sat in and I introduced myself.
They introduced me to the little boy who
was there talking to him.
So I'm.
The counselor said,
well,
ask this little boy why he's here today.
So I said,
why are you here for about eight years
old?
He says,
I'm learning how to be good,
so you learn how to be good.
I said,
is it working?
He said,
I hope so because I'm tired of getting
in trouble all the time.
And what struck me was it was,
it was,
it was a conversation,
it was a friendly conversation going on
between this older man,
his little boy.
It wasn't about,
we're going to throw you out of school,
we're going to punish you.
It was about trying to really get at the
roots of helping this boy learn to
become responsible for his own behavior.
Not Enough schools do that.
Students
would rather watch a big thing for video
than sit and read a long
page of text in a textbook.
They have an opportunity to get the
information that they wouldn't
necessarily otherwise have.
We're using the technologies to connect,
to learn.
Students can participate by using the
Internet to their advantage.